Western intelligence agencies led by the
Americans are now pretty much convinced
that the Ukrainian international
airlines plane was shot down by a
surface-to-air missile this video
emerged yesterday and it appears to show
the moment that the missile hit the
aircraft the missile is traveling from
the West
that's left to right on the screen as
you see it the aircraft is virtually
invisible in the night sky but it is
coming in the opposite direction on its
climb out of Tehran Airport just after
that moment of impact a ball of fire
possibly the aircraft spins off and
starts falling towards the ground we
know according to publicly available
data that flight PS 752 bound for Kiev
took off from Tehran Airport at 12
minutes past 6:00 in the morning local
time before leaving the airport's
airspace it made a slight turn to the
right possibly trying to return to the
runway it was flying at seven thousand
nine hundred and twenty-five feet at the
time and it was only a minute and a half
into its flight when it came down this
area here on Tehran's western suburbs is
the planes
area of impact the investigatory web
site Belling cat has worked out that the
mobile phone footage we saw was filmed
in the / and district it did that by
geo-locating the embedded data in the
video that's around three point three
kilometers from the impact area and once
Belen cat had that rough location they
could then use certain clues in the
video to build a clearer picture for
example the person who was filming was
facing to the northeast and that matches
the flight path of the aircraft they
were also able to match the building's
lampposts and other features in the
video with satellite images like these
of the area the investigators though
still have unanswered questions that
this video does not categorically clear
up very certain that this video shows an
explosion in the vicinity of the flight
path of this plane however I would not
say that this is proof that this plane
was shot down
there are still many further questions
about this event and clearly we'd like
more information before we can say
conclusively it was shot down European
intelligence sources have told us that
they're working on the theory that this
was an accident not deliberate because
of the 176 people on board the aircraft
82 were Iranian and so it just simply
wouldn't make sense really for Iran to
try and shoot it down and Tehran for its
part is adamant that it did not take
that action